et un nouvel invité nous a rejoint sur
ce plateau gilles becker bonsoir vous
êtes le jardinier en chef musée
d'archéologie nationale et du domaine
national de saint germain en laye on va
parler donc de cet anniversaire un
moment important ce 400e anniversaire de
la naissance de dolo notre paraphe ont
juste tout de même votre sentiment est
ce que vous avez l'impression d'être un
peu oublié dans cet anniversaire on
parle beaucoup de versailles des jardins
de versailles peut-être un peu moins de
saint-germain-en-laye produits tous nous
non plus trop fort on oubliera
versailles et de l'arche au futur mais
cela n'enlève tactile véritablement et
il ya un travail important qui a été
fait en tout cas par le nôtre à l'époque
à saint germain oui et avoue versailles
ça n'est que le nôtre et ça n'est que
louis xiv alors que saint germain gh on
peut parler bien sûr des premiers à la
réalisation avec louis 6 le gros mais
c'est aussi en effet vous avez tout à
fait raison françois 1er henri iv l'un
des plus beaux parcs renaissance avec
des automates hydraulique d orgue
hydraulique des des carrières désormais
mai mais sinon des rampes si terrasse au
revoir sous la neige actuellement ce
mois là j'ai réalisé forcément ce matin
c'est très joli sur la neige aussi c'est
très agréable c'est bien martin chrono
mais voilà la terrasse que l'on devine
deux kilomètres qui est en fait un abus
de l'oeil vis-à-vis du visiteur le nôtre
se fait plaisir c'est à cet endroit et
puis c'est aussi pour louis xiv toute sa
jeunesse jusqu'à 40 ans les spectacles
la danse
molière les jardins gains sur alors que
bas à versailles c'est la vieillesse s'y
ennuie c'est une prison dorée
revendiquer la jeunesse et la vitalité
de saint-germain-en-laye sur versailles
j'essaie simplement d'être objectifs et
les réalisations de de lenôtre justement
correspondra à quelle période qu'à
l'époque le nôtre est véritablement
devenu un personnage central important
avec des réalisations visibles sur saint
germain
bien sûr on va parler la grande terrasse
et donc ça s'étend jusqu'à la période où
louis xiv va partir c'est à dire une 682
pour pour versailles et là on voit le
kiosque à musique voilà du 19e
louis xiv on va partir pour versailles
mais mais sinon c'est en fait toute son
adolescence puisqu'on sait que quand il
était jeune on voit des vues de neige eh
bien ils allaient s'amuser à la luge sur
les pentes de saint germain le nôtre qui
a créé un ensemble de jardins pour près
des deux châteaux en fait puisqu'il il y
avait en tout cas deux châteaux à saint
germain en laye c'est ça en fait ce qui
c'est je pense ce qui compliquait par
rapport à versailles pour saint germain
c'est que on avait deux châteaux un
château donc voulu par françois 1er
réalisé globalement sous henri iv et
puis un autre bien plus vieux le château
vieux qui est actuellement musée
d'archéologie nationale la plus grande
collection au monde de pièces
archéologiques et donc on a deux
perspectives et on a un jardin régulier
à laleu notre jardin français et qui
regroupe donc qui réunit ces deux
perspectives celles de l'avenue des
loges celle de la grande terrasse et et
puis on a une urbanisation un peu je
vais pas dire anarchique mais un peu
galopante on est sur l'ouest parisien
c'est très plaisant et est donc la
première ligne de train qui va commencer
à morceler ce joli domaine on voit
quelques photos vous nous avez fait
parvenir justement je peux peut-être
vous laisser les commenter pour
constituer un petit peu pour toi la zone
des repas bien on a le château vieux là
c'est une début de l'avenue des loges ça
c'est des aspects voilà dujardin
régulier ça c'est des jardins paysagers
1845 un des premiers jardins paysagers
réalisés par un français en france en
raison de la création de la ligne de
train
paris saint germain en laye enfin paris
de pecs puissamment l'est voilà
donc pour ce faire je vous prends la
parole mais on a prévu cette année donc
quelques animations celle à des moments
les plus forts pour le public à savoir
le printemps et puis et puis durant
l'automne donc on aura pour le lien de
tout ça on aura des installations
d'artistes contemporains qui vont
magnifié en fait le site et donc
c'est le commissaire de l'exposition qui
est patrick amine qui les a nommés les
nouvelles folies française est donc là
on a des artistes internationaux
contemporain une vingtaine je pense que
ça va être assez amusant on va
développer tout à l'heure le programme
justement ce qui est prévu du côté de
saint germain en laye pour l'instant on
va partir pour versailles nous en
voudraient pas on va aussi s'intéresser
à ce qui se passe du côté de versailles
évoqué le le travail qui est mené là bas
l'année le nôtre a été lancé ce matin
une année de manifestations également
qui est programmé reportage réalisé en
début d'après-midi par julie rocha
soirée est clair qu en biais et
guillaume cance en étrange ballet s'est
déroulée ce mardi dans le parc du
château de versailles sous les flocons
virevoltant des fontainiers ont soulevé
la statue du bassin de latone situé au
centre de la composition des jardins
pour permettre sa restauration de leur
côté les jardiniers sont aux petits
soins pour les partenaires monde en
plein travaux on est en train de poser
les voliges en ce moment on a posé de
gazon une petite de petites parties de
gazon samedi mais malheureusement avec
la neige on le voit pas mais voilà donc
là on a encore deux mois de travail ne
je pense qu'on aura fini fin mai pour
présenter au public pour la saison le
nôtre mais on a un peu de travail là on
a un petit peu en retard on va dire ce
chantier marque le début de l'hommage
andré le nôtre jardinier du roi louis
xiv né il ya 400 ans jour pour jour le
nôtre c'est vraiment le l'honnête homme
au sens où l'entendait le xviie siècle
c'est à dire quelqu'un capable de
maîtriser de connaître être pratiqué
toutes les disciplines que ce soit les
mathématiques la géométrie architecture
la peinture le jardin la botanique
l'astronomie et cetera c'est un
personnage complètement éclectique et
c'est un petit peu cet idéal de
l'honnête homme au sens où l'entendait
le xviie siècle les manifestations
dureront toute l'année le bosquet du
théâtre d'auch détruit en 1775 sera ré
interpréter de manière contemporaine et
une exposition de sculptures d'arbres
signée de l'artiste italien giuseppe
penone rythmera les jardins à partir du
11 juin au printemps 2013 une
application mobile permettra aux
visiteurs de se promener dans les
jardins et d'obtenir des informations en
temps réel
rappelons que la touche le nôtre est
présente à saint germain en laye so me
dont saint cloud chantilly ou encore
vaux-le-vicomte mais aussi dans plus de
200 jardins modeste anonyme répertoriés
dans toute la france autant de lieux qui
célèbreront le jardinier du roi soleil
pour évoquer le travail de l'autre en ce
jour anniversaire gilles becker le
jardinier en chef du domaine nationale
de saint germain on vient de voir
quelques images du domaine de versailles
quel regard vous portez sur le travail
de lenôtre à versailles sur les
réalisations que le nôtre a pu faire il
y a travaillé tellement longtemps il a
fait plaisir hissez fait plaisir il a
fait plaisir à son mécène il faut pas
oublier que à la fin de sa vie le nôtre
étant très âgées roulant chaise à
porteurs
lorsqu'on a inauguré les fontaines c'est
louis xiv qui pousse sa chaise c'est un
dieu vivant au louis 14 ans à l'époque
donc ce n'est pas rien voilà très fort
avec le roi effectivement est ce qu'il
implique j'ai même le nom voilà travail
qui a été réalisé là-bas moi je
m'incline devant ce travail et puis
devant les travaux de restauration je
suis enchanté que mes collègues alain
baraton jaleco te convient de vous art
peuvent avoir peuvent travailler dans un
site comme celui ci et l'offrir surtout
public et et il offrir à nos enfants
voilà c'est notre but à tous nous
agents du ministère de la culture et de
la communication alors vous comment vous
travaillez en ce qui concerne saint
germain en laye notre travail en tant
que jardinier en chef quel est le
travail que vous menez est ce qu'il ya
une fidélité qui est respecté par
rapport à l'oeuvre d'origine laissé par
le nôtre commence à évoluer avec le
temps vous aviez juste juste avant un ti
une petite présentation sur le paillage
et bien voilà nous je vais je vais pas
critiquer mes collègues c'est loin de
moi cette idée
nous on essaie de réfléchir on essaie
d'adapter les techniques modernes les
techniques anciennes conservées le site
dans son intégrité
et par conséquent bien voilà nous on a
intégré le paillage et on a intégré des
techniques je vais pas dire de
développement je pense que ça n'existait
pas même jean de losne oui mais voilà
force à exactement si ça existait parce
qu'on n'avait pas le choix parce qu'on
était je vais pas dire intelligent mais
on avait on faisait avec ce que l'on
avait sous la main tout était
portez à dos d'homme ou quasiment donc
on n'avait pas le choix et bien essayons
simplement actuellement de faire la même
chose et tout particulier peut faire la
même chose donc à écouter un autre
jardinier en chef également c'est joël
cottin qu'on a aperçu dans le reportage
tout à l'heure lui est en charge des
jardins du château de versailles il nous
parle de lui de son travail mais aussi
de l' influence de lenôtre sur ce
travail se fait trente ans que je
l'entretiens wii est malade sport et
donc non faut rien changer de façon on
ne peut rien changer donc c'est très
bien comme ça parce que si tout mon
interprète le jardin à sa façon
imaginez-vous le bazar que ça peut être
la chance de faire sa carrière à
versailles on a vu de belles choses on a
vu en plus le parc changé on a eu
l'ancien parc on va dire avec tous ces
grands arbres on a eu la tempête de 99
cas complètement anéanti le parc donc il
a fallu replanter bosquet par bosquet ça
fait vingt ans de travail donc ici on
quand on rende à versailles on ne compte
pas les années donc c'est formidable une
personne importante pro versailles et on
tient toujours à lui on continue la la
commande la même direction nous on est à
versailles le nôtre à fond l'héritage
voilà les jardins nous quand on
travaille à versailles surtout dans les
jardins versailles on ne peut pas faire
autre chose que du le nôtre donc notre
travail c'est entretenir refaire un
jardin restitue un jardin comme je dis
toujours c'est facile mais l'entretenir
c'est tous les jours et longtemps
longtemps longtemps la touche le note
c'est la conception deux axes principaux
l' axe est ouest qui magnifique que tous
les touristes de la terre entière
visitez connaissent après un axe
nord-sud qui est un peu plus discret
mais aussi riche au niveau bosquet nous
dont la restauration de dubosc et des
trois fontaines qui a été fait en 2004
le bassin de neptune un plan d'eau d'un
hectare donc le terrasse l'orangerie et
la pièce de 10 8 juillet un axe
formidable mais malheureusement le
touriste a pas le temps de le voir parce
que versailles fait 850 hectares encore
aujourd'hui à l'époque je vous rappelle
6000 hectares donc c'était énorme donc
oui un peu mais on a quand même conservé
850 hectares c'est quand même bien avec
toutes les histoires qui sont passés à
versailles depuis que notre bon roi est
parti on va dire
voilà pour le témoignage de joël cottin
pour versailles et pour saint germain en
laye alors est-ce que vous avez la même
philosophie le même respect de l'oeuvre
bien sûr bien sûr ses classes et ses
protégés et puis je dirais c'est comme
un tableau à la différence qu'il est
vivant comme le disait joël c'est un
travail de fourmi et titan au quotidien
c'est peut-être pas toujours bien
reconnu d'ailleurs par les édiles
nos directeurs même si j'avoue avoir de
la chance avec monsieur mulsanne qui m'a
chargé de devenir leur présenter ce soir
parce que bien voilà on a un très beau
programme à offrir au public cette année
alors on continue justement à à se
promener entre versailles et saint
germain en laye on vous remercie d'être
venu d'ailleurs sur ce plateau au
passage parce que vous avez mis une
heure et demie avec les conditions météo
pour rejoindre le plateau de saint
germain jusqu'à saint quentin en
yvelines on va regarder votre programme
le 6 avril par exemple il ya un colloque
saint germain en laye ces jardins avec
un partenariat avec les amis du vieux
saint germain auditorium du musée et on
va évoquer forcément l'oeuvre d'andré le
nôtre c'est ça voilà alors je suis très
content que l'on en parle parce que ça
crée un peu polémique il ya eu quelques
petites coquilles en fait dans la presse
et j'en suis bien désolé parce qu'en
fait c'est une l'association des amis du
vieux saint germain qui
initie ce programme nous les accueillons
au sein de de notre établissement mais
met donc c'est une journée assez riche
avec des architectes avec des historiens
j'interviens en fin de journée enfin
voilà très éclectique sur les jardins de
saint germain sur le nôtre aussi mais
mais pas seulement vous allez intervenir
de quelle manière vous avait présenté le
travail qui a été réalisé par le passé
voilà moi je vais présenter les jardins
du 19e donc le jardin paysager d'autres
rendez vous continuer à regarder un
petit peu le programme premier de juin
rendez vous aux jardins le jardin et ses
créateurs voilà alors en jeu là c'est
une manifestation voulue par le
ministère de la culture et de la
communication est là donc avec toutes
les équipes de jardiniers nous
accueillons le public nous faisons des
visites présentant différents aspects
les aspects techniques les aspects
historiques mais on a aussi là j'en suis
très content parce que c'est béatrice
massin qui qui comment dire qu'il va
présenter en fait des broderies
chorégraphique il faut savoir que les
broderies de bruit était en fait la
retranscription écrite de des pas de
danse que l'on faisait à l'époque et
donc on a transmis sa dans le jardin
louis xiv étant l'un des grands danseurs
de l'époque on aurait pu à nos jours le
qualifier comme danseur étoile est donc
enfin on va pouvoir voir ce genre de
choses de façon vivante et public va y
participer d'une autre façon on a aussi
des lectures c'est françois marthouret
qui viendra nous faire des lectures dans
la chapelle du château et puis on
accueillera le vendredi des publics
scolaires voilà à saint-germain-en-laye
se sont tous les arts paysages et la
lecture est également littérature la
danse vous l'avez dit qu'ils seront
représentés qui vont permettre de
célébrer cette année le nôtre aussi à
saint germain le jardin est un art total
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est un art
très complet et et c'est parfait parce
que c'est un aussi un lieu qui peut
accueillir tous ces arts comme je vous
disais voilà avec de tout à l'heure la
les créations contemporaines qui sont
présentés durant tout cet été par
patrick amine puis nous avons aussi
par exemple on ne l'a pas abordé mais on
a un programme très riche avec l'office
du tourisme de la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye je vais faire une
visite à vélo parce que bien les parcs
de saint germain et puis les parcs de le
nôtre soit douze jours des départs très
très vaste et au moins on prendra le
temps d'aller à l'extrémité ses jardins
là et dont faire plusieurs dans l'après
midi il ya plusieurs rendez-vous un
parole de jardiner aussi en septembre
journée du patrimoine également à suivre
en septembre journée d'étude sur les
techniques de le nôtre en octobre tout
ça pour les prochains mois on aura
l'occasion bien sûr de revenir sur
l'intégralité de ce programme est de
venir vous voir avoir un petit peu
d'éclat mais ce sera parti à quoi
ressemble donc ce domaine de saint
germain pendant que nous continuons à
discuter on peut peut-être voir quelques
images de ce par quelques photos de
saint germain en laye
juste un mot qu est ce qui caractérise
le style de notre
est-ce qu'on peut caractériser définir
le style d'un autre oui enfin c'est
difficile je dirais que ce sont les
perspectives accès et des bosquets c'est
ce que l'on voit très bien par exemple à
versailles des perspectives donc accès
c'est la rigueur c'est parfois ça semble
un peu froid un peu un peu rude mais dès
que l'on sait garder que l'on va dans
les bosquets bien on peut avoir des
choses complètement folles
on dirait baroque et donc là c'est des
fontaines c'est des chausse-trappes
c'est cédé la boue de pirates qui sont
faits pour se perdre mais pas se perdre
seule
la philosophie de l'époque l'arrivée
comprendre le nôtre qui est célébrée
partout dans le monde dans le
département des yvelines vous l'avez vu
à saint germain la ville de versailles
également la ville de versailles a voulu
s'engager à travers plusieurs
manifestations en plus du travail mené
sur le château il y aura des
réalisations concrètes et durables qui
seront menés on écoute à ce propos le
maire de la commune françois de mazières
versailles se trouve être un peu la
capitale du paysage parce que vous avez
l'école nationale du paysage et qu' il
ya aujourd'hui une tradition c'est une
ville verte c'est beaucoup il ya 167
mètres carrés
d'espacés verts par habitant aversa elle
vous en avez 20 peu près à paris
versailles et vérité non caractérisée
par cette présence du jardin de végéta
nous voulons mettre en évidence cette
histoire à travers l'inauguration
d'éléments qui vont rester on n'est pas
dans l'événementiel on est vraiment dans
le durable pour le coup c'est à dire le
jardin que l'on va appeler la cour des
senteurs et réalisé par nicolas gilsoul
un paysagiste très grand talent qui va
nous permettre de les lire de relier la
place d'armes au quartier commerçant
quartier ça lui nous avons au bout la
venue de sow qui a été dessiné par le
autres la réalisation d'un grand jardin
dans un ancien espace du xviie siècle
qui servait de réservoir pour alimenter
les hauts du château de versailles hélas
un jardin fait par michel desvigne
également une de nos stars françaises du
paysage et puis nous avons la
réalisation aussi alors ça c'est
vraiment l'histoire reliés à la
modernité il y avait des espaces
délaissés à côté du château de
versailles des espaces sur lequel ce
sont des terrains qui appartiennent au
domaine du château et aux mises en
défense on reconstitue une allée qui
figure sur tous les plans historique a
été dessiné par le nôtre cette année a
fait 3 km2 ça va devenir une grande
piste cyclable qui va permettre de faire
le lien entre versailles saint cyr et la
plaine de versailles donc l'envoyer on
est dans une dynamique pour nous
l'intérêt le nôtre c'est non pas
uniquement de célébrer un homme
génial mort mais de dire qu'il a des
héritiers et qu'au fond existe en france
cette tradition des paysages et que
cette culture du paysage de
l'aménagement urbain est véritablement
l'excellence française
alors finalement le nôtre a une
influence partout en fait sur les
réalisations concrètes sur toute la
construction d'une ville comme à
versailles est ce qu'à saint germain ça
a été le cas aussi la ville s'est
articulée autour du travail de l'autre
aussi we should he mm dire plutôt à
partir de paris puisque lorsqu'on quitte
le louvre ou plutôt le jardin 20 le parc
le château des tuileries désormais
détruit on a quand même la kz dit
historique qui traverse la défense et
qui va jusqu'à saint germain en laye
c'est le nôtre qu'il a dessiné des
champs-elysées c'était le nom si vous
voulez profiter pleinement justement de
ce 400e anniversaire de la naissance de
le nôtre il faudra aller dans le
département des yvelines aussi bien à
versailles qu'à saint germain en laye
nous reste quelques instants peut être
pour mettre l'accent sur un des rendez
vous parmi le riche programme que vous
avez prévu cette année voilà on a un peu
parlé du printemps moi j'aimerais parler
de l'automne qui est aussi une très
belle saison on revient de vacances
avec yvelines tourisme
nous avons essayé de mettre un peu le
lac sans justement sur saint germain en
laye depuis d'autres sites mais mais
mais nous lors des journées du
patrimoine par exemple nous allons faire
plusieurs visites et puis du 8 au 22
tous les dimanches
j'ai des collègues le jardinier de
l'équipe qui vont faire des visites
auprès du public il suffit simplement de
s'y inscrire toutes nos manifestations
sont gratuites et accessibles et et
surtout on a aussi une fois de plus
béatrice massin donc chorégraphe qui
interviendra le 14 septembre dans une
petite présentation
au château de saint germain en laye mais
le dimanche 15
ce sera le spectacle un air de folie qui
sera présenté par la compagnie les fêtes
galantes au théâtre alexandre dumas de
saint germain en laye à 17 heures voilà
c'est un moment où si je pense magique à
ne pas louper c'est une date aussi à
noter dans vos agendas gilles becker
jardinier en chef du domaine nationale
de saint germain en laye qui était l
invité donc de ce 7 8 pour évoquer cet
anniversaire de l'autre on va continuer
à en parler mais je vous remercie déjà
d'être venu sur le plateau puisque je
rappelle en si vous nous suivez en
direct entre 18 et 19 heures que la
circulation est un petit peu compliquée
sur les routes du département avec la
neige qui tombe de plus en plus fort et
effectivement vous devez repartir à
saint gérard mois donc bon courage à
vous pourrez la route on repart nous
pourrons versailles avec un entretien
réalisé avec catherine pégard la
présidente de l'établissement public du
château de versailles elle nous parle
justement de l'année le nôtre des
festivités qui sont organisées à partir
d'aujourd'hui
400e anniversaire de la naissance de
lenôtre le château ne pouvait passer à
côté de cet événement bonjour catherine
pégard jeu merci de nous recevoir ici
dans le salon de la guerre là les
conditions météo ne permettait pas
d'être dehors il y en a tout de même
évoqué les différents rendez-vous vous
avez prévu autour de ce 400e
anniversaire auparavant juste peut-être
votre sentiment lorsqu'on évoque le
château forcément on pense aussi à le
nôtre c'est un personnage indissociable
du château je crois que c'est totalement
un personnage à dissociable du château
il fait partie des grands bâtisseurs de
ce château pour l'extérieur et ce qui
est intéressant dans cette année le
nôtre c'est justement qu'on revisite nos
jardins et qu'on s'aperçoit que les
jardins ont la même importance pour
l'extérieur que le château pour
l'intérieur pour l' architecture
intérieure et si j'osais la comparaison
je dirais que on se promène dans les
appartements de versailles aujourd'hui
comme on pourrait se promener demain
s'il faisait beau dans les bosquets du
château et on y voit à chaque fois des
pièces différentes comme ici nous voyons
des salons différents le paysagiste
lenôtre avait un rôle particulier auprès
de la cour s'était pas qu'un paysagiste
non d'abord il avait cette grande charge
de contrôleurs des jardins des bâtiments
des z'arts que lui a donnée auprès de
colbert le roi et donc c'est peut-être
un personnage très important qui était
pas seulement le jardinier bien sac
comme on le dit un petit peu communément
mais aussi l'architecte paysagiste
l'ingénieur le spécialiste de des
circuits hydrauliques de versailles et
puis aussi un grand collectionneur
puisque à l'occasion de l'exposition qui
terminera cette année le nôtre vous
pourrez découvrir le personnage de
lenôtre sous toutes ses facettes et en
particulier sur ce lien par spécifique
qu'il avait avec le roi auquel lorsqu'il
a pris sa retraite à l'âge de 80 ans il
a offert sa magnifique collection
collection constituée de tableaux de
poussin de bruel et puis de bronzer puis
de d'antiques et de tout ce qui faisait
la magnificence d'une collection à
l'égal des collections princières pour
le public également qu'en lorsqu'on
pense au château de versailles lorsqu'on
vient ici on veut découvrir ce qu'a fait
le nôtre je pense d'abord aux jardins
d'abord parce que rien qu'en france je
crois qu'on a répertorié 200 jardins
privés qui évoque le nôtre sans parler
des grands jardins évidemment
principes tels que celui de
vaux-le-vicomte de chantilly ou deux
sauts mais le nôtre a marqué aussi les
petits jardins comme les grands et à
travers le monde entier on retrouve des
gestes de lenôtre que ce soit à
washington pour le môle de washington
vous avez 7 ce dessin qui évidemment
évoque celui de le nôtre mais c'est vrai
des jardins impériaux du japon où nos
jardiniers vont se rendre comme expert
pour restituer le dessin le nôtre dans
ses jardins impériaux et bien c'est vrai
un petit peu partout dans le monde donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité qu'on
parle d'une année le nôtre et pas
simplement de la commémoration de la
naissance de l'otsi sur toute l'année
qu'on va dérouler des événements pour
lui rendre hommage lé jardin aujourd'hui
tels qu'ils sont présentés pour le
public sont très proche de l'origine
alors les jardins ont subi évidemment
des modifications à travers le temps des
modifications dur au goût de des
propriétaires successifs si j'ose dire
c'est ainsi que par exemple le bosquet
du théâtre d'auch a été complètement
détruit autant 2016 et puis d'autres
bosquet se sont perdus aussi un petit
peu dans l'usure du temps et dans même
dans l'usure des bois dans l'usure des
fleurs ça ça arrive lorsqu'il ya eu la
grande tempête de 1999 une partie des
bosquets a été très abîmée eh bien il ya
eu des moments où on a refait les choses
à l'identique d'autres on a changé les
choses et nous va nous continuons c'est
à dire qu'il ya des choses que nous
faisons exactement comme elle était par
exemple ce bassin de latone que que nous
dont nous commençons la restauration
mais en revanche par exemple sur ce
bosquet du théâtre d'auch eh bien on va
faire une évocation de l'histoire en le
confiant aujourd'hui au paysagiste louis
benech quels sont les grands grands
rendez vous à ne pas manquer pour cette
année le nôtre c'est très difficile
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup alors
évidemment je parlerai peut-être est-ce
qu'il faut pas mieux parler des jardins
et de la vie des jardins et des
spectacles dans les jardins parce que
comme vous savez louis xiv et sa cour et
bien vivait beaucoup dehors il vivait
beaucoup dans la fait beaucoup dans les
jardins beaucoup dans les jeux d'eau
dans les feux d'artifice donc nous
aurons tout cela j'allais dire comme
d'habitude à versailles et puis plus
encore on va voir des spectacles
musicaux
particulier pour cette année deux autres
on a confié par exemple william christie
a souhaité lui même faire un programme
particulier dans les jardins que nous ne
connaissons pas nous mêmes et qui sera
je crois une grande surprise de cette
année d'une autre et puis on aura un
grand carrousel
il n'y a pas de carrousel équestre et
pyrotechniques ici depuis très longtemps
il y aura un grand carrousel à
versailles et puis aussi un bal masqué
le 14 juin bal masqué qui aura un qui
sera sans doute très extravagant puisque
on nous l'a donc comme suit à kamel
ouali est donc ce grand bal qui va être
assez extraordinaire qui rappellera sans
doute aussi un aspect un peu festif de
cette époque parce qu'on a il faut
jamais figé le temps du roi ou le temps
des rois dans une époque c'était bien
sûr y à l'époque de l'histoire et puis
aussi le regard aujourd'hui que l'on
porte sur cette histoire et comment dans
notre imaginaire on la fait vivre vous
avez voulu moderniser aussi un petit peu
l'idée ce n'est pas de représenter tel
quel tel que c'était aussi à l'époque je
pense à la fête au grand bal par exemple
oui parce que le grand bal à l'époque il
y avait des grands bals donc aujourd'hui
on donne un grand bal dans notre époque
et le public va découvrir des secrets
des choses qui jusqu'à maintenant
n'avait jamais été révélée je pense que
ici vous savez on écoute des secrets
tous les jours et même si on y passe
toute sa vie j'imagine et donc notre
rôle à nous c'est que on dévoile des
petits bouts de versailles un peu plus
chaque jour et que c'est tout le travail
qui se fait dans la restitution des
pièces dans leurs meubles le mans deux
pièces dans les restaurations des tissus
là nous allons ouvrir par exemple neuf
nouvelles pièces très prochainement qui
sont les appartements de mesdames les
filles 2015 donc le public oui ça c'est
encore un secret va découvrir neuf
nouvelles pièces dans une vie presque à
l'identique puisqu'on a reconstitué la
bibliothèque le salon bluesy et on
traversera ces appartements en pensant
que peut-être on pourra écouter un air
de mozart de justement de la sonatt que
moubarak avait proposé pour madame
victoire une des filles de nick merci
catherine pégard pour toutes ces
précisions et puis si vous voulez
également commencer même prolonger cette
découverte de le nôtre il ya même une
application pour smartphone qui étaient
là qui permettra de visiter les jardins
avec celui qu'on a envie voir vous
expliquer les jardins c'est à dire on
pourra visiter avec le jardinier visiter
avec un architecte avoir une visite
particulière pour les enfants et je
crois que ça va être une innovation très
importante dans les jardins pour l'année
le nord par une moderniser justement
voilà c'est encore un bon exemple autour
de l'eau notre merci à vous et on
poursuit donc cette édition autour du
400e anniversaire de la naissance de
lenôtre
cette page spéciale je propose de la
redécouvrir sur notre site internet dès
demain matin dès mercredi matin
consultations gratuites vous en avez
maintenant l'habitude vous pourrez
revoir les différentes interviews celle
avec catherine pégard notamment et puis
également gilles becker le jardinier en
chef du domaine nationale de saint
germain ont l'air on continue à parler
d'actualité dans le 7-8 comme chaque
soir on va s'intéresser à renault à
présent avec cet accord de compétitivité
qui s'apprête à être signé entre
syndicats et direction